cosa fa vj ha messo un altro video in un
giorno solo mio dio bella a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono fatti j
anzi a questo nuovo blog sono stato
costretto a farlo perché ci sono
tantissime cose che vi devo dire
assolutamente mi voglio innanzitutto
scusare se per tre giorni non ho messo
video per l'ennesima volta mi scuso ma
ho fatto il mio diciottesimo compleanno
si perché io ho 18 anni anche se molti
mi dicono che non li dimostro segno
quindi va bene anche se comunque io mi
sento di avere ancora 14 anni quindi 18
è come se non ce li avessi e di
mentalità anche 78 mi sa che si comunque
a parte i palloni non si vede che camera
mia e diciamo arredata per il compleanno
festa del genere culo
e vabbè o cazzo mi stanno o dio vi
stuprano i palloncini
vabbè basta direi che possiamo
continuare va beh a parte tutto questo
sto registrando questo blog sempre col
microfono nuovo che è stato appunto un
regalo di compleanno è praticamente
questo microfono mi è stato detto che
praticamente quasi quello che usano in
radio è lo stesso mi pare che lo stesso
cosano anche sentivi e vabbè
diciamo che costa anche parecchio mi
hanno regalato mio zio che se ne intende
di ste cose e io non vedo per niente
produciamo ho capito che è meglio di
questo me ne avete dato conferma voi con
il video di happy wheels l'unica cosa
visto microfono che devo ancora
aggiustare ma che agissero a giorni
praticamente è che se dico l'apri fan
casinò assurdo perché diciamo manca il
filtro anti pop che serve appunto per
disinnescare le esplosioni che escono
quali quando dici l'api è lo prenderò
tra pochissimo quindi state tranquilli
comunque ho finito con le news diciamo
quelle noiose mele sono tolte subito per
il mio compleanno ricevuto diversi
regali è che non vi sto a dire perché
ovviamente non frega un cazzo a nessuno
però diciamo che un regalo in
particolare mi è arrivato da uno di voi
da un iscritto e amy arrivato cosa ha
causato al pacchetto e figlio è enorme
non so che cos'è
adesso andrò ad aprire in diretta ce
l'ho qui da tipo 3 o 4 giorni e non l'ho
aperto perché appunto ci tenevo ad
aprirlo nel blog
adesso tutti gli haters gemma tutto più
più di piper che più di fi anche lui più
di pai anche lui
queste per gli haters che lo pensavano
anche lui altri pacchetti nei suoi video
e quindi anche tu lo fai sei lo faccio
anch'io
molti di voi mi stanno chiedendo me lo
chiedono veramente da tanto di mettere
il mio indirizzo in modo da potermi
inviare della roba e allora una griglia
adesso vedo se farlo è deciderò in
questi giorni se farlo o meno se lo farò
lo scriverò sulla pagina di facebook
ok ragazzi sono che cazzo è sta roba ok
perfetto e gli hanno inviato una tipa in
scatola fantastico oddio ma che cazzo
c'è allora un barattolo di nutella nuovo
nuovo targa toseland airmen fantastico
blender approda anche perfetto questo è
in edizione limitata fantastico ma che
cazzo ma no mi hanno inviato un
manichino dello slang che cosa epica
[Musica]
occhi era gay fantastico lo appoggio qui
perché veramente figo perfetto che bello
c'è anche una lettera
tanti auguri fa vi sono 18 con affetto
due grandi 2
non so leggere due grandi tuoi fan
cinzia rosalia grazie mille ragazze
devo acec madonna c'è un papiro caro
favi iniziato tutto circa gennaio 2013
ho visto il tuo video sullo slider
all'inizio vedevo giusto due o tre video
settimana ma pian piano si è diventata
una droga per me se c'è un giorno in cui
non vedete video quello non è un bel
giorno per me ogni pomeriggio alle 15 in
punto sono incollati al pc aspettando i
tuoi video anche se escono all'una e
mezzo amico va bene rido anche quando
non parli insomma sorrido per tutta la
durata del video sei una persona
fantastica che merita meglio da tutto e
tutti e segno mito con affetto rosalia
grazie ville e cielo zander col pop corn
questa anche fantastica raga altra
fanart veramente epica poi c'è il
bambino digiworld che giustamente non
può mancare col verso mio è come ultimo
c'è marzo e che dice iscriviti e in
basso a destra c'è anche pre di mercury
suona con avatar di scriverla un
fantastico veramente vi ringrazio
tantissimo e stato un bellissimo regalo
e colgo anche l'occasione per
ringraziare tutti voi che mi avete fatto
gli auguri che sono stati veramente
tantissimi ragazzi io vi ringrazio
veramente tantissimo perché
cioè tutti quanti voi in generale siete
circa 22mila adesso precisamente non so
quanti siete perché ogni giorno
aumentano veramente in un numero
indescrivibile veramente ragazze giorno
l'ho mai detto ma è ovvio che per mese 3
veramente come una famiglia perché alla
fine cioè posso moltissimo tempo delle
mie giornate a dedicarmi a voi quindi è
ovvio che lo faccio per voi perché ci
tengo anche nei commenti quando come ad
esempio mi scrivete bravo favi come al
solito bel video o comunque quando
lasciate mi piace c'è veramente a me
basta basta soltanto questo perché so
con queste piccole cose che voi avete
apprezzato quello che ho fatto comunque
raga direi di andare avanti e direi di
passare a un altro pezzo forte del blog
torino comics allora ragazzi molti di
voi mi hanno chiesto di andare a torino
comics
io non sono andato né a lucca comics
ne all né a romics a lucca comics perché
diciamo ancora non avevo scoperto tra
virgolette la bellezza di questi comics
in generale e al romics non ci sono
andato perché ovviamente era nel periodo
del mio compleanno in genere non ci sono
andato
adesso che c'è il torino comics e io
sono anche di torino quindi non è che
devo prendere treni aerei sattolo cose
del genere però arrivare a destinazione
a ci sarò anch'io a torino comics
più precisamente il 14 si perché mi pare
che c'è il 12 13 e 14
quindi io ci sarò e domenica 14 quindi
per chi mi vuole incontrare o cose del
genere
sappia che comunque i 14 di
di aprile che c'è torino comics io sarò
appunto ci sarò anch'io quindi avrete la
possibilità di incontrarmi e questo è
per tutti quelli che me l'avevano
chiesto invece per quanto riguarda video
dei 20 mila iscritti mi dispiace
veramente tantissimo che non sono
riuscito a farlo uscire sempre per i
motivi del diciamo che sono stato
occupato per il compleanno non ho potuto
dedicarmi al video dei 20.000 iscritti
in principio invece sì mi ci sono
dedicate lo anche finito soltanto che è
uscito un video di 7 minuti ed era
accorto e non mi piaceva neanche tanto
quindi l'ho pubblicato l'ho fatto uscire
per tipo cinque minuti è stato è rimasto
pubblico infatti aveva tipo un centinaio
di visualizzazioni ma poi mi sono reso
conto da solo che non ne valeva la pena
e l'ho tolto allora cosa ho deciso di
fare
ho calcolato che entro domenica circa
dovremmo raggiungere i 25 mila iscritti
quindi ha saputo fare video dei 20.000
adesso è fare quello di 25.000 raga io
veramente faccio video speciale al
giorno già ne faccio uno ogni sabato più
o meno quindi veramente ragazze è
diventata una cosa anche perché poi per
fare sti video che ci metto un casino
quelli speciali intendo
e inoltre non avevano anche il tempo per
farlo quindi anche volendo non avrei
potuto farlo lo stesso quindi raga io
aspetterei quello dei 25mila iscritti
che dovrebbe arrivare comunque domenica
appena ri aggiungiamo i 25mila appena
arrivato aggiungiamo i 25mila comunque
puntuale ci sarà il video è in questo
video per farmi perdonare del fatto che
non ho fatto quello dei 20 mila iscritti
gli avevo promesso l'harlem sheikh
allora vi dico subito all'harlem sheikh
ci sarà però non sarà nel video dei 20 c
dei 25mila iscritti ma aspettate un
attimo fatemi finire il video dei 25mila
iscritti uscire appunto domenica è il 16
il 16 di aprile fino al 20 aprile
io andrò in gita scolastica con la mia
classe a praga dato che siamo una classe
molto tranquilla
abbiamo deciso di fare un harlem sheikh
quindi nel quale ci sarà appunto anch'io
quindi l'harlem sheikh direi che è molto
più divertente si è fatto appunto in
gruppo quindi pubblicherò l'arno in
shame io della mia classe appena
torneremo da praga state tranquilli e
nel frattempo per temporeggiare diciamo
farò una cosa che è molto peggio del
video dell'anno in sé ma molto peggio
c'è la sfida due decenni bunny molti di
voi la conosceranno praticamente
consiste nell consiste nel praticamente
mettersi più marshmallow un possibile in
bocca e ogni volta che se ne mette uno
bisogna dire la parola achab i bagni
hanno fatta già in moltissimi youtubers
hai dato che me lo avevate chiesto in
tanti perché ovviamente vi piace vedermi
soffrire maledetti diciamo che lo faccio
per temporeggiare sulla land sheikh farò
prima la sfida due decenni vani sono
quasi sicuro che lo metterò nei video di
25.000 ma non completamente sicuro
comunque va beh nel caso sarà alla fine
del video e per quanto riguarda due
chabib anni invece per l'harlem sheikh
quando tornerò là praga dopo il 20
aprile comunque
ok allora direi riguarda un attimo la
scaletta dalla microfono l'ho detto
quindi devo prendere la roba che mi
evita di dire proprio corpo però senza
spaccare i timpani poi del torino comics
ve l'ho detto è appunto ci sarò il 14
quindi ripeta un'altra volta il video di
25.000 iscritti uscirà se tutto va bene
questa domenica dipende se li
raggiungiamo entro domenica in teoria ci
dovremmo raggiungerli comunque vedremo
dalle 16 a 20 aprile non ci sarò perché
ho una gita scolastica a praga
ma nonostante questo sto progettando di
mettere dei video diciamo in pianificata
ovvero che tu stabilisce una data
precisa
ad esempio metto che ne so 18 aprile
mentre sono via e si pubblicano da soli
anche se non ci sei
quindi non so se riesco a farne proprio
4 in modo da coprire tutti i quattro
giorni qui non ci sono però di sicuro
adesso vedo se riesco a fare qualcosa
diciamo per farvi sentire il meno
possibile la mia diciamo assenza direi
che per il video è tutto io allo slider
vi salutiamo come al solito raga selvi
dove è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
in ogni video trovate nella descrizione
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
e noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video
bella ragazzi